Hi, my name is Idris and you're about to watch my brand-new trailer for my film "Yardie"
I really hope you enjoy it and see in cinemas soon
Dez young Jamaican and him he loses his brother his only family
We take him the story through these eyes and his journey
Kingston Jamaica: King Fox controls the streets. "Deliver the goods to Rico". "You're going to send me to London?
London
Everyone beams to be immersed in it, the smoke and the sound. First time in London, true?
Yes, First time. Trust me you're going to love it here.
We wanted to make a three-dimensional character that was weighty and complex. "I can't go on like this"
Will you go in the righteous or will you go down damned?
Yardies, they have trouble. Hope people enjoy the beauty of this film is exciting and Gribble.
I sent you to London so you wouldn't start a war in Kingston
When I was a boy my brother would always ask me which way you're gonna go. Will you go the righteous or will you go the damned?
I will you go with the damned
This is a story about the path I chose
Kingston Jamaica King Fox control the streets
He told me to forget about my brother. "Redemption. Deliver the goods to Rico when it is done you let me know."
You're going to send me to London?
London
All I had to do was deliver the Coke to Rico. But I didn't like it. First time in London, true? Yes, First time. Trust me, You're gonna love it here.
Four years I haven't seen you. My name is 'D', 'D' for daddy? 'D' for Dennis
I came here to change my life, to get away from Kingston
Look at yourself
The grief never left you, like a mad dog.
Now, your brother getting shot down like that is ancient history
They are trouble. I asked you to deliver the goods to Rico but I trusted you but  Rico is a liability.
I have to deal with it
You understand?
Rico wants to kill you
Can't have this nonsense around me.
Could've just gone back to Jamaica
10 years ago, they killed my brother
Sometimes a man has to choose his own path
I can't go on like this.
I sent you to London so you wouldn't start a war in Kingston